more than any big cat
leopards spend most of their time in
trees it's here that they eat sleep even
mate this leopard is in a tree in the
Mala Mala Game Reserve in Kruger
National Park South Africa
the reason leopards spend so much time
in trees is because other cats like
lions q leopards and because hyenas and
wild dogs love to steal their kills
this forces leopards to master the art
of the arboreal scrambled never-failing
to know exactly which branch will
support its weight
yeah oops well then almost never failing
[Music]
sometimes a leopard must maneuver
himself and his dinner up a tree the
leopard has incredibly strong neck
muscles that allow it to log prey double
or triple its weight up into its leafy
home where it won't be troubled by
scavengers and predators you think that
stalking and killing an Impala would be
the hard part wouldn't you but new turns
out the hard part is knowing which limb
support all that weight
[Music]
and after all that trouble an
opportunistic hyena grabs the kill and
scoots off okay so the hungry leopard
goes out and kills yet another Impala
and is trying to drag it up to the tree
another hyena chances buy and decides to
play a little game of tug-of-war as you
ponder who will win this struggle
consider this pound for pound hyenas
have the strongest jaws in the Mala Mala
Game Reserve nothing is going to make
this hyena let go now except maybe this
am a lioness
the hyena takes off and the leopard
immediately bounced upward with its kill
but the lioness decides that she has
eyes for the prize and also bounds up
the tree survival here can be a subtle
game and this time the leopard has
gauged the tensile strength of the tree
branches perfectly even though the
lioness is inches from a juicy meal she
knows that she's too heavy to climb any
higher
[Music]
at last the leopard gets a well-earned
meal in peace